البدايه من ملف اموالي ايران المجمده حيث
اعلنت او اعلنت في طهران عن الافراج عن
ثلاثه مليارات دولار من ارسلته ايران
المجمده في العراق بفعل العقوبات
الامريكيه وكانت الحكومه العراقيه طلبت من
واشنطن حل مشكله المستحقات الماليه لايران
عن صادراتها من الغاز والكهرباء الى
العراق من بغداد ينضم الينا مدير مكتب
الجزيره وليد ابراهيم ومن طهران ينضم
الينا مراسلنا عمر هواش وابدا معك عمر
يعني حينما نقول افراج فهو بالضروره لا
يعني ان ايران ستتسلم ثلاثه مليارات دولار
هنالك تعقيدات اكثر من ذلك
بالفعل زين هذا المبلغ لن يسلم الى طهران
نقدا بل انما طهران سوف تشتري به من
العراق او عن طريق العراق سلعا اساسيه
بالدرجه الاولى مواد
غذائيه ومعدات صحيه وادويه كذلك سوف
يستخدم لتغطيه موسم الحج اي يدفع للمملكه
العربيه السعوديه ايذاء الخدمات التي
تقدمها للحجاج الايرانيين الذين يبلغ
اعزهم نحو 87 الف حاج هذا الكلام كان
لاسحاق
او يحيى الاسحاق مدير غرفه التجاره
الايرانيه العراقيه المشتركه الذي اعلن عن
هذا الامر لكن اذا ما نظرنا الى التحركات
الدبلوماسيه الاخيره بين طيران وبغداد قبل
اسبوعين كان هناك اتصال هاتفي بين وزير
الخارجيه الايراني حسين امير عبد الهيان
ونظيره العراقي فؤاد حسين
الخارجيه الايرانيه حينها شكر عبد الله
هيان العراق على تحويل هذه الاموال لاجل
توفير الخدمات للحجاج الايرانيين اضافه
الى شراء السلع الاساسيه هذا ماذا يعني
زين يعني ان هناك كانت تحويل لهذا الاموال
خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين ويجري هذا
التحويل او اكماله في هذه الايام وان
الاعلان اليوم هو فقط عن الرقم الذي اعلنه
او اعلنته غرفه التجاره الايرانيه
العراقيه المشتركه اي ثلاثه مليارات دولار
لكن زين من المهم ان نقول ان هذا هذه
المبالغ الايرانيه في العراق ليست فقط
ثلاثه مليارات دولارات هي هناك من يتحدث
عن رقم يتجاوز العشره مليار دولار كل هذه
الاموال او المستحقات الايرانيه هي نتيجه
تصدير ايران للكهرباء للغاز الى العراق
خلال الفتره الماضيه يتم بين
اقوال اخرى تسديد مبلغ من هذه الديون
ويؤجل المبالغ تؤجل مبالغ الاخرى التي هي
بطبيعه الحال بحاجه الى الضوء اخضر امريكي
العراقي لا يزال يلتزم بالعقوبات
الامريكيه المفروضه على طهران مثله مثل
الكثير من الدول وهذا الافراج جديد لابد
ان يكون قد تم بالضوء اخضر امريكي واذا ما
نظرنا الى المباحثات التي اعلن عنها في
العراق بين العراق وعمان المستحقات لايران
لا يمكن فصل هذا الامر ايضا عما لم يتم
الاعلان عنه حتى الان بشكل رسمي بشان وجود
اي مباحثات تتعلق بالمفاوضات النوويه
بالافراج عن اموال رنين مجمده او تبادل
السجناء بين طهران والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه عمر هواش سؤال سريع ايضا هنالك
السياق اموال الاراده المجمده ليست فقط في
العراق في اماكن كثيره من العالم
والافراج عن قيمه هذه الاموال والسماح
لدول يعني مثلا كوريا الجنوبيه
قيل انها ستسدد ديون ايران او مستحقه
واجبات ايران الماليه للامم المتحده ما
السياق الكبير الذي تجري فيه هذه
الافراجات
هناك سياق كبير لكنه لم يكتمل زين من
المعروف ان المفاوضات النوويه بين طهران
والدول الغربيه الدول الاوروبيه ومن خلفها
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه متوقفه منذ
شهور طهران تهدف الى تحرير هذه الاموال
ضمن ما يسمى هنا مفاوضات رفع العقوبات
الامريكيه او حتى الاوروبيه عن طهران هناك
سبع مليارات دولار اعلن عنها سابقا في
كوريا الجنوبيه هناك نحو مليارين دولار في
اليابان هناك مبلغ مماثل في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هناك ما يقارب بين 20
الى 30 مليار دولار في الصين ايضا طهران
تسعى الى الافراج عن هذه الاموال سواء
برفع العقوبات عبر المفاوضات مع الدول
الغربيه ومن خلف الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه او مفاوضات مع الثنائيه مع هذه
الدول نجحت في هكذا مفاوضات مع العراق
نجحت سابقا كذلك مع كوريا الجنوبيه عندما
سدد الطهران رسوم عضويتها في الامم
المتحده عن بعض اموالها المجمده في كوريا
الجنوبيه وليد ابراهيم من بغداد
العراقيون يتحدثون عن
انهم وصلوا لتفاهم مع الولايات المتحده
بخصوص المليارات الثلاثه لكن هل يريدون
اكثر هل يتحدثون عنه ما يشترون اليه بحل
مشكله
امدادات الكهرباء الايرانيه وقيمتها هل
يقصدون العشره مليارات
زين العراق ليس الان فقط وليس فقط من خلال
اللقاء الذي جمع وزير الخارجي العراقي
والامريكي العراق منذ البدايه عبر عن
موقفه هو يريد ان يضع حد لهذه المشكله
بمعنى اخر العراق قال انه مستعد لدفع كل
هذه الاموال الاموال المترتبه على العراق
جراء شراء الطاقه الكهربائيه والغاز يتحدث
العراق عن 11 مليار دولار او بنحو 11
مليار يورو عفوا وليس دولار والعراق يقول
انه مستعد لدفع هذه الاموال بل ان العراق
يقول ان كل هذه الاموال هي مجمده في حساب
خاص للطرف الايراني في مصرف التجاره
العراقي التي بي اي وهو المصرف المسؤول عن
السياسه التجاريه الخارجيه للعراق يقول
العراق ان الاموال موجوده في هذا المصرف
لكنه ينتظر ضوء اخضر امريكيا في هذا
الاطار العراق لا يريد له لا يريد ان يصنف
على انه بلدا يخرق او لا يمتثل
الامريكيه فيما يتعلق بالعقوبات الامريكيه
المفوظه على ايران هذه هي المشكله وعندما
يصل العراق وهذا ما تحدث به اكثر من مسؤول
عراقي قالوا عندما نصل الى توافق امريكي
فنحن مستعدون لطلق اي اموال الى طرف
الايراني ما حدث مؤخرا من اطلاق هذه
الاموال كان واضحا انه ياتي في سياق
اللقاء الذي جمعها وزير الخارجيه العراقي
مع نظيره الامريكي في الرياض هذا اللقاء
تحدث فيه وزير الخارجيه العراقي بشكل واضح
انه يريد العراقي يسعى الى وضع حد لهذه
المشكله لانه لا يريد ان يواجه اي مشكله
في موضوع شراء الطاقه الكهربائيه خاصه في
هذا التوقيت بالذات درجات الحراره بدات
ترتفع بشكل كبير جدا في بغداد وقال ما
راينا في السنوات الماضيه انه في مثل هذا
التوقيت فان هذا الموضوع يتحول الى مشكله
كبيره حرجه كل الحكومات السابقه واضح جدا
ان حكومه رئيس الوزراء العراقي الحالي
محمد الشيعه السوداني لا تريد ان تتورط او
لا تريد ان تكون في نفس الموقف الذي وقعت
فيه الحكومات السابقه عندما تواجه الشارع
العراقي في موضوع ازمه الكهرباء وهذا ما
تحدث عن المستشار الاعلامي لرئيس الوزراء
العراقي قبل قليل عندما قال ان العراق دفع
منذ فبراير شباط من العام الجاري حتى الان
مليار ونصف مليار يورو وان هناك مليار
يورو في الطريق سيتم دفعها قريبا كل هذا
يقول عن المستشار الاعلامي ان هذا
سيساهم في تحسين واقع الطاقه الكهربائيه
في العراق مره اخرى اقول زين ان العراق
حريص جدا على تسويه هذه المشكله وحريص جدا
على دفع كل الاموال لكنه في نفس الوقت لا
يريد ان تتسبب هذه الازمه او هذه المشكله
في علاقه متشنجه مع الطرف الامريكي يا
العراق جيدا اهميه التوازن في العلاقه بين
حليفين ستراتيجيين ايران وامريكا هو لا
يريد ان يغضب ايران ويقول انه غير مستعد
لدفع هذه الاموال على العكس هو يقول انه
مستعد لكن في نفس الوقت الذي يريد ان يغضب
الطرف الامريكي وعلى ويصور على انه لا
يمتثل للعقوبات الامريكيه ضد ايران وليد
ابراهيم مدير المكتب الجزيره في بغداد
شكرا جزيلا وشكرا لعمر هواش من طهران